et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Dominique fort bonjour bonjour d'être
avec nous vous êtes secrétaire d'État à
la ruralité on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour un interview en partenariat
avec la presse régionale représentée par
Christelle Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche
bonjour Oriane bonjour Dominique force
bonjour on va évidemment parler des
questions en réalité elles sont
nombreuses elles sont importantes mais
d'abord et ça concerne aussi un
finalement les Français en zone rurale
évidemment j'en ai de mobilisation hier
dans toute la France cette crise des
carburants qui s'est étendue cette
journée de mobilisation il y a eu
107.000 participants sur le ministère de
l'Intérieur 300 000 selon la CGT est-ce
que les syndicats ont réussi leur
mobilisation pour vous en fait j'ai pas
d'avis sur le succès ou pas de cette
manifestation moi j'ai envie de dire à
quel point on est solidaire des
difficultés que rencontrent nos
concitoyens dans la ruralité d'abord
vraiment les infirmiers les
aides-soignants et puis tous les tous
les aides à domicile on utilise beaucoup
plus sa voiture en environnement rural
donc voilà beaucoup de solidarité par
rapport aux difficultés rencontrées
ensuite dire que on est dans une grève
qui aujourd'hui
la solution c'est le dialogue social je
crois qu'il y a eu un accord majoritaire
qui n'est pas respecté par certains
syndicats mais le dialogue social vous
savez c'est la direction et et les
salariés le gouvernement ne peut que
voilà ne peut pas intervenir ne peut pas
augmenter les salaires c'est vraiment
dans ce dialogue social que va naître la
solution je pense qu'elle a la solution
aller trouver puisqu'il y a un accord
majoritaire j'espère sortir de certaines
le gouvernement est à la manœuvre depuis
plusieurs jours le président de la
République a même repris la main hier
dans ce dossier depuis lundi pardon a
réuni les ministres finalement ça a eu
assez peu d'impact sur la mobilisation
est-ce que ça signifie qu'il a perdu la
main et que le gouvernement a perdu la
main dans ce dossier
comme je viens de dire en fait je pense
que le gouvernement ne peut que
on va dire citer la direction à
dialoguée aboutir encore une fois je
crois qu'il faut on prête beaucoup au
gouvernement qui devrait faire ci ou
devrait faire ça aujourd'hui le dialogue
social c'est l'affaire de la direction
des salariés donc a-t-on perdu quoi que
ce soit dans d'enseigner une
généralisation du conflit aujourd'hui on
parle des centrales nucléaires
alors quand on parle d'augmentation de
salaire il est évident que
on mobilise du monde donc est-ce que ça
va durer est-ce que ça va s'amplifier
est-ce que ça va se réduire moi je peux
vous dire je suis sur mon champ qui est
la ruralité j'essaye d'accompagner nos
concitoyens qui sont en grande
difficulté mais vous dire que le
gouvernement a perdu la main franchement
je pense pas par exemple de la
mobilisation dans les centrales
nucléaires est-ce qu'on doit craindre un
impact de ces mobilisations cet hiver
personnellement je ne souhaite pas je
pense que aujourd'hui nos concitoyens et
les salariés sont extrêmement conscients
de à quel point on a besoin de notre
énergie nucléaire on est dans un mix
énergétique qui fait qu'on a besoin
d'énergie des carbonées
on porte un projet de loi pour en faveur
des énergies renouvelables la sobriété
oui les énergies renouvelables on a
besoin de nos centrales nucléaires et
d'énergie décarbonée donc je pense et
j'appelle à la responsabilité des
salariés on va parler des finances des
collectivités les mers euros en sont
inquiets évidemment comme d'autres élus
mais d'abord un mot sur le 49-3 qui
devrait être dégainé aujourd'hui par
Elisabeth borne pour faire adopter le
budget alors que Bruno Le Maire il
reconnaît que les débats se sont bien
passés qu'il n'y a pas eu d'obstruction
est-ce que du coup en ayant recours si
tard le gouvernement s'est permis dans
une impasse
je trouve la question
particulière parce que je pense que le
49-3 je vais d'abord rappeler que cet
article de la Constitution et puis dire
à quel point il a été utilisé par Michel
Rocard Premier ministre 28 fois dans les
années 80-8 à 91 François Mitterrand est
président de la République et donc mais
en fait c'est un article qui est là pour
être utilisé quand on n'a pas une
majorité pleine entière à l'Assemblée et
quand on a de l'obstruction je crois
qu'encore cette nuit on est à 2000
amendements non non traités donc je
crois que le moment est venu
effectivement pour utiliser le 49.3
cependant nous dire que cela fait trois
semaines et que les débats se sont bien
passés et qu'on aurait pu l'utiliser
plus tôt en fait je pense que c'est un
outil extrêmement intéressant qui dit
que les débats sont bien passés mais je
souscris je trouve qu'ils se sont bien
passés et c'est vrai qu'ils ont été
nombreux et nourri et la première
ministre a toujours dit qu'elle irait au
bout du dialogue du débat avant
utiliser le 49-3 si on devait utiliser
le 49-3 qui rappelons-le et quand même
un article qui nous permet qui permet à
la France d'être gouverné alors suite à
ce 49-3 le projet doit être finance va
être réécrit par le gouvernement des
amendements qui ont été votés à la
majorité dans l'hémicycle et je pense
notamment à l'amendement proposé par le
modèle sur les super dividendes où elle
exit taxes vont ne vont
vraisemblablement pas être repris est-ce
que c'est normal que des amendements qui
ont été votés à la majorité ne soient
pas maintenue dans ce texte alors vous
en savez peut-être plus que moi moi je
ne suis pas au coeur des discussions sur
les amendements qui vont être repris ou
pas je pense qu'il y a une petite
centaine d'amendements qui ont de fortes
chances d'être repris
je pense que cet amendement auquel vous
faites allusion
est un amendement qui est quand même
orthogonal par rapport à la politique
que nous portons au gouvernement
je vous disais la politique
gouvernementale vous savez elle était
déjà celle du mandat précédent cette
stabilité fiscale cette cohérence
fiscale cette attractivité de la France
par rapport aux autres pays européens
moi j'en suis fier de pouvoir afficher
ici aujourd'hui on est sur le chemin du
plein emploi c'est bien parce que notre
attractivité là c'est bien parce que nos
entreprises ont confiance dans notre
pays donc à un moment donné des
opportunités d'augmenter les impôts il y
en a toujours quand on est en situation
de gouvernance donc moi je peux
comprendre que le modem est porté cet
amendement je pourrais comprendre que
nous ne le retenions pas voilà ce que je
vous dis aujourd'hui mais je ne suis pas
à la manœuvre sur ces sujets comme vous
l'avez compris les élus ils sont
inquiets de la fragilité de leur finance
les élus ruraux également bien
évidemment les difficultés liées à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie les
communes rurales elles bénéficient du
bouclier énergétique il va y avoir une
augmentation de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement également pour les
communes mais est-ce qu'il faut en faire
plus pour pour ces communes rurales
est-ce qu'il faut aller notamment
jusqu'à indexer la DG sur l'inflation
alors vous dire quelques mots puisque on
en vient sur le sujet de déruralité en
France vous dire que la première
ministre m'a laissé jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour
évaluer ce que
l'efficacité de la politique publique en
matière de ruralité c'est quand même le
rappeler septembre 2019 181 de mesures
l'agenda rural avec 3 milliards injectés
exactement et c'est mon prédécesseur
Joël Giraud qui a porté sur les fonds
bâtissements c'est 180 mesures cet
agenda rural donc il est important de
voir trois ans après on a eu plusieurs
confinements septembre 2019 mars 2020 on
est confiné on a eu les élections
municipales en 2020 2022 les élections
présidentielles législatives donc quel
citoyen et quelle mer est vraiment
conscient que 3 milliards d'euros ont
été injectés sur les territoires ruraux
c'est 180 mesures beaucoup de mesures
donc jusqu'à la fin de l'année autour de
trois axes une évaluation très objective
par l'igedd qui est un institut qui va
évaluer la politique publique et les 180
mesures de façon très objectifs d'ici le
mois de décembre d'ici le mois de
décembre moi même qui aurait fait une
trentaine de visites sur des territoires
ruraux d'ici la fin de l'année j'en suis
à 18 aujourd'hui j'ai vu neuf régions
sur les 13 donc je fais une sorte de
tour de France dans votre puisque vous
sillonnez la France vous l'avez dit sur
780 mesures qu'est-ce qui a marché
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché qu'est-ce
qu'il y avait des mesures qui n'étaient
pas les bonnes est-ce qu'ils font
changer qu'est-ce qui reste à faire on
va vraiment se féliciter sur le sujet
des maisons françaises en état 2600 et
on entend un besoin d'avoir une
capillarité plus grande de se rapprocher
encore plus du citoyen en ruralité donc
oui ces maisons France service en
complément construire de nouvelles alors
il n'est pas impossible c'est Stanislas
Guerini avec lequel nous travaillons sur
ce sujet que l'on puisse en avoir une
petite centaine ou 150 complémentaires
mais je pense que là 600 là les 2600
c'est à la fin de l'année on est autour
de 2400 mais il y a des engagements qui
font qu'on sera 2600 à la fin de l'année
et j'entends des mères dire à comment
ils ont besoin de maisons en service à
un niveau de
collectivités inférieurs sur le
numérique avec mon collègue Jean-Noël
Barrault on est sur le le déploiement du
haut débit fixe donc la fibre optique
sur le haut débit mobile la 4G la 5G on
est on a opéré une évolution en
partenariat avec les départements c'est
souvent ensemble quand on arrive à être
efficace et bien nous arrivons à un
niveau de couverture excellent bien sûr
qu'il nous faut continuer mais ça fait
partie de ces investissements et de ses
décisions qui au sein de l'agenda rurale
il y en a beaucoup mais je voulais citer
ces deux-là ensuite sur les sujets sur
lesquels je suis absolument consciente à
quel point nous devons accélérer c'est
les déserts médicaux c'est la mobilité
donc les déserts médicaux vous avez vu
cette quatrième année qui est portée par
François Braun et Agnès Firmin le Bodo
quatrième année par les sénateurs ça a
été voté au Sénat hier également
euh on est on est très heureux pourquoi
bah parce que ça va être pour nous dans
le PLF SS donc la sécurité sociale une
quatrième année d'internat en médecine
générale et qui va nous permettre de
d'être de proposer à ces jeunes internes
les zones peu denses donc en très grande
partie 2/3 en ruralité probablement et
un tiers en environnement plus urbain
puisque effectivement il y a aussi des
problématiques de désert médicaux sur
l'immobilité est-ce que vous avez déjà
des pistes de travail parce qu'on voit
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les zones rurales
notamment qui souffrent des problèmes
approvisionnement naissance certaines
personnes du tout prend leur voiture
donc ça accroît encore les problèmes qui
étaient préexistants est-ce que vous
avez des pistes de travail sur ce sujet
oui vous dire absolument mais vous dire
que ce que je pressens après ces trois
mois
importer ce portefeuille des ruralité
c'est qu'on va avoir les élus locaux
avec qui on va pouvoir travailler
maintenant la main et les mers de ruraux
pour agir mais on va aussi avoir toutes
une association je pense à famille
rurale par exemple que nous accompagnons
et qui sont pour nous des maillons
essentiels pour mettre en oeuvre des
politiques publiques localement et
pourquoi je pense à la famille rurale
parce que ils portent un projet de
déplacement solidaire et qui est
extrêmement utile dans les dans les
départements de France dans lesquels ils
sont en fait c'est tout sa voiture des
bénévoles voilà qui font du covoiturage
avec leurs propres voitures ils sont
dédommagés un prix au kilomètre qui
rembourse l'essence et l'amortissement
de la voiture et donc on est vraiment
sur des sujets qui ont du sens parce que
on est dans du lien social puisque
souvent ils embarquent trois quatre
personnes dans leur véhicule on est sur
du bénévolat on est sur un niveau de
capillarité très fine et donc je pense
que c'est des idées pas plus tard que
lundi soir je rencontrais un porteur de
projet très innovants donc vous voyez
l'associatif mais aussi des initiatives
entrepreneuriales qui portent un projet
extrêmement étonnant que je trouve
intéressant d'explorer qui vise à
embarquer vous savez investi sur 1500 km
de petites lignes dans nos ruralités et
donc c'est embarqué dans le train un peu
de fret avec des voitures électriques et
qui permettent à nos passagers
d'embarquer dans le train à la descente
de la voiture d'embarquer dans des
véhicules électriques pour se rendre
chez eux et ramener le véhicule
électrique à la gare après mais vous
voyez des initiatives j'en ai perçu SNCF
absolument au travail vous allez en
discuter dans le cadre du CNR ou
certains ne peuvent être mis en place
avant alors le troisième axe je vous
disais mais visites sur le terrain
environ une trentaine d'ici la fin de
l'année toutes les régions en tour de
France des régions une évaluation des de
la politique je vous ai dit au DD et
puis des groupes de travail donc les
cinq groupes de travail du CNR ou
évidemment la composante ruralité je
veillerai à ce que cette composante
ruralité soit prise en compte vous voyez
bien les déserts médicaux sur le CNR
santé problématique bien spécifique sur
le Bien vieillir avec Jean-Christophe
combe bien sûr le Bien vieillir en
ruralité donc tout sera à l'intérieur du
de ce Conseil national de la refondation
il y a autre chose cinq sujets du CNR
sur lequel évidemment là moi je n'ouvre
pas de groupes de travail puisque je
serai au sein de ces groupes de travail
du CNR et qui vont cranter vraiment les
territoires locaux locaux et ruraux et
puis cinq autres groupes de travail que
j'ai initié pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière pour aussi évaluer mais aussi
être force de proposition être innovant
sur quel sujet on va trouver culture et
patrimoine plein d'idées ont émergé de
rendez-vous que j'ai fait avec Rima la
ministre de la Culture bien sûr le sujet
de sport il y a associatif je crois
beaucoup au sport vecteur d'intégration
sociale dans nos territoires ruraux
alors bien sûr des sujets comme logement
habitat mobilité donc c'est déjà trois
groupes que je vous cite l'attractivité
de nos territoires ruraux et puis un
dernier groupe qui est sécurité vie
citoyenne dans nos ruralités sécurité
pourquoi parce que je m'aperçois que de
nombreux maires aujourd'hui quand je
rencontre 30 40 mers dans tous mes
déplacements j'essaye de demander au
préfet de réunir plusieurs maires il a
toujours un pour me dire que voilà acte
de violence et donc il nous faut
travailler ce sujet particulièrement au
niveau de la ruralité
du ministère de l'Intérieur de
nombreuses mesures évidemment mais parmi
les mesures il y a la création de 200
brigades de réalité est-ce que pour vous
on imagine que c'est une autre chose
mais est-ce qu'il en faut plus et est-ce
que vous allez suivre justement le
lancement la création de ces brigades de
réalité le suivre de très près
j'ai un message à Gérald Darmanin
je m'en réjouis pourquoi on faudrait-il
plus on n'a pas commencé à voir
l'efficacité de ces 200 premières c'est
énorme de s'embrigades de gendarmerie on
en est extrêmement heureux les mères du
rural en sont extrêmement heureux les
citoyens sont extrêmement heureux on
aime notre gendarmerie dans les
territoires ruraux donc pourquoi il
faudrait-il plus aujourd'hui moi je
pense qu'on va déjà voir comment on
déploie ces 200 brigades l'efficacité la
parole de prévention de la gendarmerie
qui est majeur alors là vous ne savez
parler de nombreux groupes de travail
nombreux groupes de réflexion c'est des
choses qui vont prendre du temps est-ce
qu'il y a pas des mesures d'urgence à
prendre aujourd'hui pour assurer les
Français dans les zones rurales qui se
sentent délaissés depuis plusieurs
années aujourd'hui les mesures d'urgence
elles ont été votées cet été franchement
avec le PLF r donc la loi de finance
rectificative c'est quand même 430
millions d'euros qui ont été votés c'est
quand même un certain nombre de mesures
sur le prix de l'énergie qui ont été
prises ici la fin de l'année avec des
chèques énergie donc moi je pense que
les mesures ont été prises vraiment cet
été et puis je suis extrêmement heureuse
de pouvoir porter des projets pour 2023
et d'avoir le temps de porter des
projets et de porter à la première
ministre vraiment ministre de tutelle
Christophe Béchu un projet pour la
ruralité un nouveau souffle pour notre
agenda rural au premier trimestre 2023
et d'avoir un peu de temps pour le
mettre en oeuvre et justement on va
parler environnement avec Christelle
mais une question puisque vous parlez
énergie vous allez au Congrès des Maires
des élus de montagne il y a une
inquiétude évidemment parmi les élus de
montagne c'est à l'ouverture des
stations de ski avec la hausse de
lecture des prix de l'énergie est-ce que
vous allez prendre des mesures
spécifiques pour aider ces maires de
montagne qui doivent ouvrir leur
stations de ski mais qui se retrouvent
souvent face à des difficultés
financières alors on en a déjà prise je
peux vous dire que le sujet principal à
la fois des mères qui ont donc des
remontées mécaniques en régie ou bien
des entreprises qui le gèrent moi j'ai
fait un certain nombre
d'assemblées générales d'élus locaux ces
dernières semaines et je vais à la même
effectivement demain
la dernière que j'ai faite c'est la même
des stations de montagne SM à la fin
cette ils sont une centaine de mères à
l'époque EDF essayait de leur faire
signer un contrat de trois ans sur
l'énergie autour de 500 euros du
mégawattheure aujourd'hui on est à 180
euros et je disais à cette époque il
faudrait qu'on arrive à 200 euros nous
sommes arrivés à obtenir ces 180 euros
donc je pense que les stations de
montagne vont pouvoir fonctionner cet
été et je pense donc il y a pas
d'inquiétude cet hiver
il y a pas d'inquiétude c'est à dire il
y a pas de commune qui ne pourront pas
ouvrir leur station de ski ma
connaissance et je prendrai la mesure
demain lors de l'assemblée générale de
la NEMA en Aveyron vous allez leur faire
des annonces du coup il y aura
je vous disais parce que effectivement
j'ai le sentiment qu'à 180 euros du
mégawater mais ce que je voudrais
profiter de ce point pour vous dire
c'est à quel point certaines stations de
montagne ont déjà embarqué les énergies
renouvelables je voudrais citer
effectivement ils ont équipé toutes les
remontées mécaniques de panneaux
photovoltaïques extrêmement intéressant
ils arrivent à alimenter à hauteur de 30
% les énergies dont ils ont besoin pour
fonctionner donc il faut encourager les
investissements en énergie renouvelables
particulièrement à la montagne alors
aussi Thiais Christophe bechy il y a
quelques instants vous êtes sous la
totale des ministères de la transition
écologique depuis le début de ce
deuxième quinquennat on va beaucoup
d'énergie et l'actualité en effet il
nous y oblige mais Emmanuel Macron a
fait de l'environnement et la transition
en des points forts de sa campagne on
entend peu parler d'autres sujets comme
biodiversité comme la gestion des forêts
qui pourtant était elle aussi au centre
de l'actualité comment vous l'expliquer
que vous entendiez peu parler moi je
partage pas ce point de vue je travaille
maintenant la main avec ma collègue
Bérengère Couillard qui est en charge la
biodiversité qui fait un travail
remarquable Christophe Béchu qui je le
rappelle est à la tête d'un ministère
transition écologique et cohésion des
territoires nous sommes cinq autour de
lui avec une bonne cohésion au sein de
l'équipe et je peux vous dire que c'est
quand même
depuis ce mandat que l'on a le président
de la République et la première ministre
ont décidé de regrouper ses deux
ministères et notre objectif c'est de
grander la transition écologique dans
les territoires vous travaillez moi j'ai
envie de vous dire ça avance très bien
pourquoi parce que d'abord il faut
prendre conscience que on franchira une
étape dans le domaine de la transition
écologique quand on sera opérationnel
tous ensemble c'est à dire ici on est
sur Public Sénat il faut que cette
transition écologique elle soit
embarquée du citoyen au gouvernement
avec le maire l'intercommunalité le
département la région et ce n'est
qu'ensemble et aujourd'hui on travaille
sur plein de sujets vous le savez bien
sur la non art officialisation des sols
à horizon 2050 la baisse de
l'artificialisation autour de 50% 2030
ce sont des sujets sur lesquels nous
travaillons d'arrache-pied pour
embarquer la transition écologique à
tous les niveaux et de pour parler d'un
sujet qui a été au cœur de l'actualité
cet été avec les incendies sur les
forêts par exemple
dans le budget les effectifs de l'ONF
sont seulement sanctuarisés et pas
augmenter est-ce que c'est suffisant là
on est sur le champ de compétences de ma
collègue Bérengère brouillard moi je
sais pas vous dire
si véritablement ce budget devrait être
augmenté en tout cas il faut un travail
remarquable moi je suis dans mes
ruralité très confrontée au sujet des
forêts je vais vous dire les ruralité
qu'est-ce que c'est aujourd'hui en
France me parler Insee c'est 22 millions
de Français un tiers de la population
française sur 88% du territoire donc 44%
c'est-à-dire la moitié est agricole le
reste ce sont des forêts des villages
c'est nos campagnes la montagne mais je
suis évite évidemment confronté mais
de la biodiversité ce sont pour moi des
institutions partenaires avec lesquelles
nous travaillons le budget pourrait être
augmenté mais le budget de beaucoup de
nos administrations pourraient être
augmentés
moi je suis très solidaire d'un
gouvernement qui veut quand même et qui
porte cet objectif de revenir en dessous
des 3% de déficit à horizon de 2026 donc
je trouve que on va protéger les
Français avec notre budget 2023 on
pourrait peut-être faire plus mais c'est
à Béranger et Christophe Vichy de
répondre à un dernier mot peut-être un
peu plus politique on a constaté lors
des dernières élections municipales
législatives présidentielles une poussée
du rassemblement national dans les zones
rurales et un vote qui s'éparpille sur
tout le territoire comment vous
l'interprétez est-ce que c'est la preuve
que le gouvernement n'a pas su répondre
aux préoccupations de ce monde rural
durant le précédent
j'ai envie de dire que c'est un peu mon
combat
et que j'ai l'intime conviction que
ce vote est un vote effectivement de
révolte est un vote
qui nécessite que je passe beaucoup de
temps sur les territoires
sur le comment je vais pouvoir améliorer
la qualité de vie de nos concitoyens
c'est vraiment mon combat mon souhait le
plus cher j'y passe beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'énergie et je pense que il y
a parmi ce vote des extrêmes des deux
extrêmes il y a un vote un peu de
révolte je vous disais que cet agenda
rural a été voté en septembre 2019 je
vous disais que Mars 2020 confinement il
y avait d'autres préoccupations pour que
nos concitoyens véritablement mesurent à
quel point on avait pris en compte les
difficultés qui rencontrent journalistes
c'est un problème de communication
pédagogie mais j'ai envie de dire les
deux si vous me le permettez je pense
qu'il y a un problème de lisibilité et
il y a un problème peut-être
d'efficacité mais c'est l'évaluation de
la politique publique que j'aurais d'ici
la des années qui me permettra de le
dire mais c'est aussi un problème de
pédagogie et puis peut-être de choses
innovantes que l'on va
identifier que l'on va porter dans ce
deuxième souffle voilà comment je vois
les choses aujourd'hui mais c'est
véritablement mon combat l'amélioration
de la qualité de la vie de nos
concitoyens j'étais mère jusque en
juillet
2022 puisque tout début le 7 juillet
j'ai passé la main et donc je suis assez
habité par l'envie d'améliorer la
qualité de vie de nos concitoyens merci
Dominique fort merci beaucoup
ce matin avec de la dépêche Christelle
c'est la pression monte sur Macron c'est
à la Une de votre journal ce matin merci
Christelle
[Musique]